Guten Morgen Thomas.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Ja, heute mit ohne Linus, denn der Linus, der macht Urlaub. Er hat sich gedacht, der Stress.
Jede Woche mit Netzpolitik hat, das macht ihn fertig. Das reißt ihn in den Abgrund
und äh deswegen ist er jetzt äh auf Aromatherapie äh an einen unbekannten Ort geschickt worden und äh.
Er hat's verdient.
Trinkt, trinkt den ganzen Tag Granderwasser und äh kommt langsam wieder. Die die lässt sich die Seele ordentlich durchspülen. Ja, stattdessen äh begrüße ich äh Thomas, Thomas Lohninger, hallo.
Warst ja schon ein paar Mal bei uns, groß vorstellen muss man dich nicht, aber ähm du bist jetzt äh wie das zu erwarten ist, auch äh in Wien und wir machen da hier ein kleines Ferngespräch. Ja und äh ist super, du bist sozusagen für diese Woche mal einge äh gesprungen,
und äh wie das dann auch zu erwarten äh ist äh werden wir dann den einen oder anderen Österreich äh Schwerpunkt damit dann hier auch nochmal äh einflechten. Das trifft sich auch insofern ganz gut, als das da ja wohl auch grade einiges äh
in Wallung ist, ne? Ja.
Den netten Nebeneffekt, dass ich ähm irgendwie meinen meine Wette mit andere vielleicht doch noch gewinne. Wir haben nämlich gerade so was laufen, wer von uns beiden am häufigsten im Podcast bei euch ist und jetzt ist es wieder auf Gleichstand vier, vier.
Ein Battle, ein Podcast-Battle. Wow.
Eigentlich bin ich ja jetzt Aushilfsmoderator, das sollte auch mehr zählen.
Ja, es gibt dann, gibt noch mal einen Bonuspunkt, würde ich sagen, doppelt.
Ja, nicht schlecht irgendwie. Im Zweifelsfall, weil falls es zu einer Stichwahl kommt, können wir dann ja so einen, so einen richtigen Battle äh Netzpolitik, Battlerap machen.
Ja, da machen wir dann eine Sondersendung draus, das äh kommt sicherlich ganz gut an.
Aber bis dahin äh müssen wir uns hier noch mit den normalen äh Dingen des Lebens herumschlagen lassen. Unser Dauerbrenner und Lieblingsthema Leistungst äh äh Schutzrecht äh ist in Deutschland äh immer noch nicht vom Tisch, ganz im Gegenteil.
Nun äh heißt es, dass es äh ja, nun doch ganz kurzfristig
durchgepaukt werden soll und zwar schon an diesem Freitag, den äh ersten März, obwohl es ja zuletzt noch Gerüchtel, dass äh die Unterstützer Front leicht.
Wegbröckelt, dem scheint wohl nicht zu sein, so zu sein.
Ja, also
Ich habe das Ganze nicht nicht zu stark äh verfolgt, äh naturgemäß, aber das scheint jetzt auch irgendwie ein bissel äh schnell zu sein, weil das letzte Mal habt ihr noch so getan, als wenn das vielleicht gar nicht kommt. Und jetzt, wenn am.
Wir haben's so getan. Na ja, also es es gilt immer noch so ein bisschen, meine, mein, meine Wette, ich war immer noch der Meinung, bin auch immer noch der Meinung, das ist alles so äh.
Und äh bekloppt und kann am Ende auch äh nicht die Bohne überleben.
Aber na ja, man ist ja nun auch häufig auch schon von anderen Realitäten überzeugt worden und ich habe da überhaupt gar nicht den Anspruch immer richtig äh zu liegen, nichtsdestotrotz
ist der Drops aber auch noch nicht ganz äh gelutscht und wenn man ähm halt auch mal grad so äh die Twitterwolke äh verfolgt hat. Gestern, da äh gab's dann doch auch schon so einige.
Äh
Ist etwas populäre Politiker gesagt, aber sagen wir mal, in der in sein Netz äh äh Debatte etwas sichtbarere Personen, wie zum Beispiel eben der Peter Tauber
CDU, der tatsächlich in einem längeren Blogartikel äh dargelegt hat
nach wie vor für Unsinn äh findet, da die ganzen vorgetragenen Bedenken für absolut berechtigt und äh den ganzen Move nicht tragen will und auch schon angekündigt hat, dagegen zu stimmen.
Also es macht auf jeden Fall so den Eindruck,
Als ob so die Koalitionsrason hier nicht so ohne Weiteres einfach auf Durchmarsch schalten kann, sondern dass ähm.
Na ja, innerhalb der Koalition und insbesondere innerhalb der Fraktion äh der CDU,
Also,
auch bei der FDP gibt's einige, die das gesagt haben, also hier Jimmy Schulz, wiederum auch äh einer der profilierteren äh Netz ähm Politik engagierten in der FDP äh hat
ebenso angekündigt, dagegen zu stimmen, also in in beiden Lagern findet das äh statt. Ich kann jetzt gerade gar nicht sagen, wer da äh wackeliger ist,
Nur das sind natürlich jetzt auch die Leute, die sich, sagen wir mal, netzpolitisch auch schon so weit herausgewagt haben, dass,
Ihnen das wahrscheinlich auch äh vernichtend zukommen würde, wenn würden Sie in diesem Fall auch einfach davor stimmen und dann müssen Sie sozusagen da Scheiße fressen und ähm,
Abwägen gegen ihren eigenen Neumond.
Wie üblich ist das eigentlich im im Bundestag, dass ähm die Abgeordneten ihr freies Mandat nutzen, also gegen die eigene Fraktion stimmen.
Das ist sehr unüblich. Ähm es herrscht halt eigentlich generell so ein äh Blockzwagen.
Dass man halt einfach mit seiner Fraktion stimmt, das heißt egal wie man dann im Einzelnen äh drüber nachdenkt, es gibt sozusagen so eine, so eine so Vorentscheidung im Kopf äh
die Mehrheit der Fraktion das will, dann habe ich das mitzutragen, äh damit wir regierungsfähig sind, bla, bla, bla
Ja, natürlich der Abgeordnete ist auf dem Papier der unabhängig. Typische Ausnahmen davon sind in Deutschland solche moralisch-ethischen Sachen, ja, was weiß ich, wenn's hier um
Abtreibung geht oder ähnliche Fälle und so so grundsätzliche Bewertungen, wo man aber auch sieht, wo der Riss gar nicht mal nur in der Regierung, sondern eigentlich auch über alle
Parteien äh so mitten durchgeht, ja, wo sich typischerweise auch so grade also bei so Religions äh Themen
da hast du also bei den Grünen meistens äh denselben Fallout wie auch bei der CDU, dass du da so ein so ein konservativ.
Kirchennahen
Teilhas, der da einfach eben anders drüber denkt, als vielleicht mehr so die Libertär äh real aufgestellten Leute und wenn es sich also nicht um eigentlichen Sinne, um ein politisches Projekt handelt
eher um so eine politische Absegnung oder Weichenstellung auf Basis moralischer Änderung in der Gesellschaft, dann
heißt es dann eben auch schnell mal ja wir geben jetzt hier die Stimme frei und und jeder kann hier irgendwie abstimmen wie er will, dann gelten einfach diese Grenzen nicht, aber in solchen Momenten, wo es grade um solche.
Ähm.
Politischen Projekte geht und das ist ja hier auch so ein Ding, ne, was vor der Wahl nicht groß besprochen wurde, dann mir nichts, dir nichts auf einmal in diesem Koalitionsvertrag auftauchte
wo wir eigentlich die ganzen letzten Monate auch in der Diskussion darum beleuchtet haben, dass es sich hier also wirklich so ein Lobbyprojekt allererster Größenordnung handelt,
Das ist natürlich ähm eigentlich ein typischer Fall für,
wird hier die Fraktion an die Kandare genommen und gesagt, so hier entweder ihr seid äh äh mit uns oder ihr seid gegen uns, ja. Ähm,
insbesondere vor dem Hintergrund, dass wir eben
schnell auf die Sommerpause zu rauschen und danach Wahlen sind und im Prinzip das jetzt die letzte Chance ist, dieses Gesetz auch erfolgreich auf den Weg zu bringen.
Von daher hätte ich jetzt sehr viel mehr erwartet. Ähm die Leute, die sich jetzt dagegen gemeldet haben öffentlich, wenn man die mal so zusammenzählt,
dann sieht es nicht jetzt so aus, als ob das jetzt schon eine eine relevante,
sei, um da die äh Kernabstimmung in irgendeiner Form in die andere Richtung zu bewegen, also das wird vermutlich nicht reichen. Da müssten jetzt wahrscheinlich nochmal so zehn, zwanzig Leute umkippen.
Da ist meiner Auffassung nach nicht unbedingt mit zu rechnen. Wenn es also jetzt tatsächlich zu dieser Abstimmung kommt, dann könnten wir durchaus äh,
in der Situation sein, dass es ein beschlossenes Gesetz gibt.
Das muss ja in Deutschland nicht viel heißen, wie wir gerade beim Zugangserschwerungsgesetz äh gesehen haben. Da äh ging dann ja die Debatte äh wild nach oben. Und auch hier,
einfach auch die absurde Situation
eigentlich auch große Teile des des ähm Lobby-Apparats, die einfach üblicherweise so bei solchen konservativen Projekten schön äh hinten in der zweiten Reihe steht und äh äh im Chor mitsingt.
Ja, also aber auch so BDI, also bunte Industrie und das Schwergewichtige ähm Stimmen, aber vor allem auch die gesamte äh Wissenschaft beziehungsweise auch wirklich die der Teil der Forschung, der sich eben explizit mit Urheberrecht,
auseinandersetzt
eigentlich alle unisono gesagt, das ist einfach Quatsch, das bringt nichts, das ist äh äh rückwärtsgewandt, das ist äh eher schädlich als äh hilfreich. Keiner will das äh alles äh äh doof, ihr riecht nach Lulu, ich will zu meiner Mama. Aber
es kommt halt einfach.
Nicht an, weil einfach der Politapparat an der Stelle dann einfach anders funktioniert. Hier ist einfach mal intern ein Versprechen gegeben worden, das soll gehalten werden. Und da äh stört natürlich sowas wie Realität einfach nur.
Ja, das ist grad wirklich äh so das Battle. Du hast diese diese Hinterzimmerabsprachen, die es hier eindeutig geben muss und die Realität auf der anderen Seite. Und äh
irgendwie scheint es eine offene Frage zu sein, wer sich von den beiden durchsetzt. Ähm.
Dann auch noch diese Kampagne, die jetzt neu dazu ähm
aufruft so im letzten Moment rum dieses Leistungsschutzrecht äh nochmal Öffentlichkeit zu bringen und zwar unter Informationsverzicht DE
ähm kann man sich eintragen, dass man ähm keine,
Presseverleger, Produkte, so sprich keine Tages- oder Wochenzeitungen in den meisten Fällen mehr kaufen wird, wenn ein Leistungsschutzrecht kommt.
Ja, schöne Idee vielleicht, aber äh ich meine, in Anbetracht der Anzahl der Personen, die da jetzt dahinter stehen, zweiundneunzig Personen, die irgendwie ein Ausgabenverzicht pro Jahr von äh achtundzwanzigtausendneunhundertzwanzig Euro
bekannt gegeben haben, ich glaub das kratzt die jetzt irgendwie nicht nennenswert, ich glaub auch dass die Zeit für Kampagnen an der Stelle also im Sinne von dem Versuch einer, einer Öffentlichkeit zu erzeugen.
Ist jetzt einfach zu spät. Ja, wenn das Ding jetzt irgendwie durch.
Man hat ja auch schon gemerkt an der Kampagne von Google et cetera, dass bringt's irgendwie auch alles nicht. Das ist einfach ein Thema, ist einfach zu unsexy, das das versteht keiner, das ist einfach zu komplex.
Ich denke, dass Gesetz wird sich letztlich selber zu Fall bringen, weil es ist halt einfach so, alle Studien, auch die zuletzt rausgekommenen, sagen halt.
Es gibt hier einfach ernsthafte verfassungsrechtliche Probleme und wenn man sich jetzt auch insbesondere den letzten Entwurf anschaut, also das, was jetzt vermutlich am Freitag dann tatsächlich,
auch zur Wahl gestellt wird, wenn man dann nicht eben wieder auf den letzten Metern nochmal irgendwie eine Vorlage ändert, das ist ja auch alles durchaus schon mal da gewesen, dass da so in der Nacht nochmal das ein oder andere,
umgeschrieben wird. Da gibt's dann also auch wieder völlig absurde äh Formulierungen,
von ähm kurz mal schauen, ich hatte mir das jetzt gerade nicht genau, ja genau, einzelne Wörter also es gibt nochmal so eine Einschränkung, ja es würde ja nicht gelten, wenn äh einzelne Wörter oder kleinste Textausschnitte äh,
sozusagen nur davon betroffen sind. Ja, also da freut sich äh äh.
Also da da wundert sich schon äh der Betrachter und der Jurist reibt sich die Hände, weil das ist halt mal wieder eine eins A Arbeitsbeschaffungsmaßnahme äh äh für für Gerichte und und und Rechtsanwälte, weil ich meine, was bitte ist,
kleinste Textausschnitte. Also.
Kleinst, im Sinne von Kleinst möglich, ja, ein Buchstabe, einzelne Wörter steht dann wiederum davor, ist dann also einzelne Wörter oder kleinste Textausschnitte, also ist kleinste Textausschnitte dann.
Wie viele Wörter sind das dann? Ja, also was ist kleinst? Wenn einzelne Wörter ist vielleicht.
Drei, also die einzelne wird es einzelne Wörter, also ein Wort, man darf ein Wort nehmen ohne gleich äh eingesperrt zu werden, das ist ja wirklich sehr nett, ja, dass man auch mal ein oder ein oder zitieren darf. Äh oder kleinste Textausschnitte. Sind das dann,
Drei Wörter oder sind das fünf oder sind das zwanzig?
Ja, was ist kleinst? Ist kleinst relativ zum Gesamttex, darf man irgendwie ein Prozent äh zitieren und wenn das Ding halt äh äh selber nur
umfasst, dann darf's nur einer sein und dann wenn's hundert Sätze sind, also es ist einfach vollkommen gummi und gaga und keiner weiß eigentlich, was hier gemeint ist.
Und es gibt halt ähm.
Durchaus bedenken, dass das überhaupt verfassungsrechtlich Bestand hat. Und das war ja eigentlich auch meine These eigentlich von Anfang an.
Dass bei diesem LSR es eigentlich nicht gelingen kann, bei dieser unscharfen Ausrichtung mal wirklich klar zu definieren, was man eigentlich will, weil.
Man noch nicht mal den Eindruck hat, dass diejenigen, die dieses Gesetz vorantreiben, eigentlich so genau wissen, was sie wollen, ja. Ist es jetzt ein Kampf gegen Google, ist es der versucht da eine Einigung zu erzielen et cetera. Es ist einfach vollkommen,
unklar und man hat auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl, es ist eher so ein Gesetz, was einfach mal beschlossen werden soll, um,
einfach ähm klar zu äh machen, so plakativ, dass wenn Springer äh,
sagt, dass dann eine Regierung auch
Hot zu machen hat, egal ob das jetzt sinnvoll ist oder nicht. Da geht's sozusagen eigentlich nur noch um diesen Akt als Seuchen und das ist das, was es natürlich an der Stelle auch besonders unangenehm macht
Weil man hier ohne Not äh eigentlich irgendwas beschließt, um einfach ja, um es einfach beschlossen zu haben.
Wir werden am Freitag äh schlauer sein oder auch nicht,
Das wird sich zeigen, auf jeden Fall wird es so eine gewisse Netzöffentlichkeit äh erzeugen. Ich vermute mal, wir werden dann einen Beschluss sehen und dann geht das in die nächste äh Runde mit entsprechenden Verzögerungsmaßnahmen
ähm vom Bundesrat, der ja sowas dann noch abzusegnen hat, ist da wahrscheinlich nicht sehr viel zu erwarten. Dazu ist dann auch äh die SPD zu verquirlt, aber,
ja, ich denke am Ende wird es alles aus irgendwelchen Gründen zurückgenommen werden müssen.
Hm, ja, aber trotzdem, wenn das durchgeht, das ist ganz schöner Präsident.
Ja. Was haben wir denn auf EU-Ebene dann noch zu vermelden?
Genau, ähm es gab ein paar Abstimmungen ähm in der Agenda der Datenschutzreform auf EU-Ebene. Äh ich glaube darüber habt ihr ja schon in den letzten Folgen immer wieder ein bisschen berichtet.
Und äh ja, wir müssen vielleicht auch ein bissel über diesen Prozess reden, also was jetzt passiert ist, ist, dass ähm in der letzten Woche äh zwei Opinien
waren, das heißt so Ausschüsse, die eine Meinung zu dieser Datenschutzreform abgeben,
maßgeblich für die Entscheidung des EU Parlaments ist. Wenn auch nicht bindend.
Also Ausschüsse des Europäischen Parlaments. Mhm, welche Ausschüsse waren denn das?
War der Ausschuss für Binnenmarkt und Verbraucherschutz, der hat schon davor abgestimmt und in der letzten Woche war Industrieforschung und Energie, der Ausschuss und Beschäftigung und soziale Angelegenheiten der INPL.
Und äh die haben sich alle drei in Summe eigentlich recht ähm ja Datenschutzfeindlich und US-Lobby freundlich verhalten in ihrer Meinung, die sie abgegeben haben.
Und ähm ja, jetzt müssen wir mal wissen, dass diese dieser Entscheidungen in diesen drei Ausschüssen an sich noch nicht bindend sind, aber.
Wir haben jetzt noch einen vierten Seuchenausschuss, der auch nochmal eine Meinung abgibt, das Ganze dann am achtzehnten, neunzehnten März, das ist der Rechtsausschuss Juri.
Und dann kommt das in den Liebe-Ausschuss, in der großen über bürgerliche Freiheiten und Justiz und Inneres.
Liebe.
Kein langes I.
LEBI. Oh.
Und ja, der wird wahrscheinlich im April abstimmen und äh damit äh haben wir mal so ein grobes Meinungsbild im Parlament und vor allem haben wir dann auch schon einen klaren Bericht, was sozusagen die Meinung des Parlaments zum,
Kommissionsvorschlag zur Datenschutzreform ist.
Mit dem wird dann der Jan-Philipp Albrecht dann ähm grüner Abgeordneter aus Deutschland, der hier äh so der äh,
man nochmal, Reporteur ist in dieser Sache, der verhandelt dann damit mit dem Rad. Ähm,
Was heißt das Ganze? Ähm das ist schon sehr bedenklich, wenn man sich äh wenn man sich ansieht, der,
Vorschlag, den die Kommission damals gemacht hat, zur Datenschutzreform
dem das Ganze gestartet ist. Der war eigentlich schon recht gut in großen Teilen. Da gab's immer noch verbesserungswürdige Dinge, aber das war im Grunde schon so im Geiste eines äh starken Datenschutzes, Konsumentenschutzes aufgebaut,
und äh was wir jetzt aber sehen ist, dass das Parlament hier der Einflussvektor für für noch mehr viel viel mehr US-Lobby ist, als das schon bei der Kommission der Fall war,
und dass sie einfach äh immer mehr Bestimmungen verwässert werden, Ausnahmen hinzugefügt werden,
so zentrale Punkte, die einfach dafür notwendig sind, dass dieses Gesetz in der Realität angewendet werden kann und auch wirklich eine eine Verbesserung bringt, die man nicht sofort wieder umgehen kann. All das wird jetzt hier eben.
Heraus reklamiert und hier wird herumgedoktert, deswegen ist es einerseits kritisch zu sehen,
Andererseits muss man auch sagen, da kommt auch noch die äh Situation im Rat dazu, die auch nicht so toll aussieht. Und hier ist auch vor allem irgendwie,
lustigerweise Deutschland und Großbritannien gerade in in so einer Koalition
aus sehr guten Gründen, also beides sind gegen die Datenschutzreform, aber Deutschland, weil sie fürchten, dass sie den deutschen Datenschutz verringern könnte.
Großbritannien, weil sie fürchten, dass sie den ähm.
Verbessern könnte.
Genau, ja.
Ja, gar nicht so einfach.
Ja ähm man muss sich nochmal vor Augen führen, äh diese Datenschutzreform ist eben ein Gesetz, was äh wenn es in Kraft tritt, sofort in allen siebenundzwanzig Mitgliedsstaaten in dieser Form
gilt. Es ist nicht wie eine EU-Richtlinie, die man erst dann in allen siebenundzwanzig Staaten national implementieren muss und und Umsetzung Spielräume hat
sondern das ist wirklich ein Text, der für alle gilt. Was auch ein großer Vorteil wäre, weil da muss man irgendwie so Internet, das ist schon etwas, dass man gerne einheitlich geregelt hätte.
Der generelle Kampf
eigentlich in Europa, dass wenn man sich auf irgendwas einigt, das natürlich äh äh Länder, die im Prinzip schon da äh weitere gehende äh Situationen geschaffen haben, dann im Zweifelsfall in so einem Kompromiss zurückstellen müssen. Das gilt ja auch für Umwelt, et cetera und andere
Sachen, da ist jetzt der Datenschutz natürlich in dem Sinne überhaupt gar kein anderes Thema. Aber.
Aber noch natürlich eine Frage der Umsetzbarkeit, weil irgendwie ist es toll, wenn Deutschland schön starken Datenschutz hat ähm gegen Facebook hilft er gar nichts. Also dazu braucht man einheitliche europäische Regeln, die auch Mechanismen beinhalten, wie man
dazu zwingen kann, sich an diese Gesetze zu erhalten. Und all das wäre jetzt vorgesehen in diesem Vorschlag.
Mhm. So oder so äh das Ganze zieht sich jetzt auf jeden Fall noch weit in den April äh rein. Gibt's denn eigentlich schon irgendein Datum, an dem das ganze final abgestimmt werden soll?
Das kann man so jetzt noch nicht sagen. Also, wie gesagt, wenn
dieser dieser Liebeausschuss mal eine Entscheidung getroffen hat, dann wird mit dem Rat verhandelt, dort wo die Minister der einzelnen Länder sitzen. Und ähm das Ganze kann noch mehrmals hin und her gehen, wenn man sich nicht einig wird und die Gefahr ist auch, dass
ähm einfach es in dieser Legislaturperiode nicht mehr zu machen. Also die läuft ja noch bis zweitausendvierzehn auf EU-Ebene,
Und ähm wenn wenn man es nicht schafft, bis dahin sich zu einigen, dann,
wieder dieses Diskontinuitätsprinzip und alles wieder auf Anfang gesetzt und da muss man von vorne anfangen. Das will man natürlich nicht, also es ist jetzt schon die Frage, dass man ähm
da kommen wir auch zu diesem Punkt, was man tun kann, den eigenen Abgeordneten sagt und auch der eigenen Regierung im Zweifelsfall, dass man einen starken Datenschutz auf europäischer Ebene haben will und dass das jetzt nichts ist, äh wo
Industrieinteressen mal vorgreifen sollten, sondern wirklich auch etwas, wo Europa sich auszeichnen kann. Das ist irgendwie äh das ist so ein klassischer Punkt, wo es wahnsinnig viel Sinn macht
Gesetzgebung zu machen. Und äh deswegen wär's irrsinnig schade, wenn der nicht zustande kommt.
Hm. Ja, sah noch irgendwas weiteres.
Ähm.
Punkte ähm die du da äh erwähnt hast, auf der wir wollen, Datenschutz Punkt AT Seite.
Äh ja, die die kommen eigentlich von äh der digitalen Gesellschaft, die haben die für unsere Kampagne in Österreich übernommen.
Und ich werde nicht alle ziehen runterbeten, ich will nur auf ein Paar zu sprechen kommen, weil ich glaube, dass es damit anschaulicher wird, worum's eigentlich in dieser Reform geht.
Ich glaube auch, dass das was ist, was die meisten Leuten heute immer noch nicht klar ist, deswegen bringe ich das auf. Ähm die die Reform selbst, also das dieses Gesetzespaket ist riesig. Äh das liest fast niemand durch, aber,
da eben so ein paar Grundpfeiler, die ganz wichtig sind, um es überhaupt zu verstehen und zu begreifen und die die wichtigste Frage ist schon die, was sind überhaupt personenbezogene Daten? Also welche Daten sollen geschützt werden?
Und da ist sozusagen das Umdenken, dass es nicht mehr nur die klassischen personenbezogenen Daten sind, wie.
Name, äh Geburtsdatum, Adresse, sondern auch Daten, mit denen ich ähm dich einfach identifizieren kann, auch wenn ich nicht weiß, wer du bist.
Mit dem er sozusagen einen Bezug zur Person herstellen kann.
Genau, also so was wie Cookies, äh IP-Adressen, Browser Fingerabdrücke, diese Dinge. Ähm dass man diese Dinge halt auch schon als,
personenbezogene Daten ansieht. Das ist so der erste Punkt. Ähm der zweite ist äh eine ganz lustige Sache, das berechtigte Interesse
Ähm es gibt im Datenschutz ja so gewisse Ausnahmen. Du darfst immer Daten verarbeiten, wenn zum Beispiel ein Gesetz dich dazu zwingt, dass du sie verarbeitest.
Und ähm dann gibt's noch andere Ausnahmen, wie zum Beispiel, dass du die Daten verarbeiten musst, damit du überhaupt die Leistung erbringen kannst, die der Kunde von dir verlangt.
Weil sonst einfach nicht geht.
Genau und dann gibt's jetzt da äh in dieser Aufzählung an Gründen auch noch den schönen Punkt berechtigtes Interesse.
Und äh berechtigtes Interesse kann so gut wie alles sein,
ein berechtigtes Interesse von einem direkt Marketingunternehmen kann es sein, mir Spam zu schicken und deswegen die Daten, egal woher sie sie haben, für diesen Zweck zu nutzen.
Ja, ne, das hatten wir ja hier auch schon mal äh diskutiert, diese diesen äh und das scheint ja auch so ein bisschen ein äh Kernpunkt in der Auseinandersetzung mit den einzelnen Lobbygruppen zu sein, wie eben dieser Punkt zu fassen ist
Und es ist klar, wenn das berechtigte Interesse äh im wesentlichen so definiert wird, dass man sagt so, naja, wir wollen das. Ja, äh dann also haben wir auch ein berechtigtes, also sozusagen aus jedem Interesse einen berechtigtes Interesse wird,
Das ist äh glaube ich auch so ein bisschen einer, der Knackpunkte. Was würdest du sonst noch herausheben?
Ähm ganz wichtig ist auch noch die Einwilligung des Nutzers. Das heißt, ähm ab ähm es ist ja eigentlich so das Grundparadigma des Datenschutzes ist es ja äh, dass sowieso alles erlaubt ist, aber der User muss zustimmen.
Jede Art der Datenverarbeitung ist möglich, solange der User darüber Bescheid weiß und und sein Sanktus dazu gegeben hat,
und genau dieses Einwilligen des Users ist natürlich auch ein sehr heikler Punkt, wie muss das im Detail ausschauen,
ist das ein vorausgefülltes Häkchen auf der Webseite oder muss ich da explizit erst zu ähm draufklicken, damit sich die Einwilligung gegeben habe,
inwieweit muss ich informiert werden, wenn sich hier Dinge ändern.
Und kann ich dieses Häkchen überhaupt auch nicht anklicken. Das heißt, kann ich irgendwie einen Dienst nutzen, ohne dass ich meine Daten dafür hergebe?
All diese Fragen hängen hiermit zusammen und das ist ein genauso wichtiger Punkt,
Ähm dann werde ich hier ein paar überspringen. Das war ein einer der interessanteren wäre vielleicht noch so Datenportabilität. Ähm das kennt man von Twitter, dass man dort seine Tweets runterladen kann.
Was was dieser Punkt mein ist, dass die Daten, die irgendein Unternehmen über mich gespeichert hat, dass ich mir die auch,
in einer möglichst wiederverwendbaren Form schicken lassen kann. Das heißt, dass ich mir das, was äh irgendwo über mich vorliegt und vor allem eben bei,
Social Media Seiten kann das eben mein ganzes Archiv sein an Posts und unter Umständen auch mein soziales Netzwerk
ähm dass sich diese Daten sozusagen ähm wirklich mir offline verfügbar machen kann und wahrscheinlich dann auch mitnehmen in einem neuen Service.
Das heißt so, das was wir jetzt irgendwie noch über,
bei, bei, bei App dot net zum Beispiel sehen, dass man sich mal die anderen sozialen Netzwerke anschaut und anhand derer versucht, gleich so so ein paar Freunde mitzunehmen.
Falls das irgendwann einmal von den eigentlichen Anbietern, wenn das Twitter zum Beispiel nicht mehr erlauben würde, dass man sich dann trotzdem eben immer noch diese Daten auf einem legitimen Weg holen kann.
Ja. Ja, das ist ja, sagen wir auch so, einer der Schlüsselpunkte, wenn es um das Phänomen des Logins geht.
Nicht das Einloggens, sondern das ist ein Logins, also das der das Einschließen in einen Dienst, so nach dem Motto, ja klar, du kannst ja hier jederzeit deinen Account
killen, aber so deine Fotos, deine Videos und so weiter, die löschen wir dann auch, ne? Und das ist ja im Prinzip ein Bedrohungsszenario
der Stelle und wenn man das eben mal klar regelt, dass man selbstverständlich auf die selbsterstellten, gespeicherten vorgehaltenen äh Daten auch vollkommenen Download-Zugriff hat, sofern es sich sozusagen um den eigenen Content handelt
Wäre ja schon mal was äh äh gewonnen, weil das eben dann in einem zumindest wenn auch nicht ohne Aufwand, aber dann zumindest doch ermöglicht, äh äh auf eine andere Plattform,
umzuziehen.
Ja und wenn ich jetzt ähm auf bei allen Seiten Betreiber schon seit X Jahren bin, ähm dann sind's vielleicht wirklich die Daten, die mich dort halten,
und äh das heißt, das ist das ist auch äh etwas, was es braucht für einen agilen Markt, dass ich meine Kunden äh äh zwar schon irgendwie binden kann durch meinen Service, aber nicht einsperren kann, dadurch, dass ich einfach ihre Daten nicht mehr hergebe,
ähm vielleicht so ein letzter Punkt, der damit zusammenhängt, ist einfach, dass es ein äh was was oft
leider somit Recht auf Vergessen benannt wird. Eigentlich ist es ein Recht auf Löschung, ähm dass man, wenn man eben einen Dienst verlässt, wenn man kein Kunde mehr ist von einem Unternehmen, dieses Unternehmen auch dazu zwingen,
können sollte, dass die eigenen Daten dort gelöscht werden.
Mhm.
Genauso wichtiger Punkt. Äh da gibt's noch viel mehr und die ganze Reform, es ist ein ein Fass ohne Boden, aber
zehn Punkte sind so einer der umfänglichsten und und am leichtesten verständlichsten ähm Aufbereitungen davon nicht gefunden habe. Wir werfen das in die Links und auch noch ein paar mehr Materialien, wen das interessiert.
Genau, um einfach mal nochmal klar zu machen, wir hatten ja hier auch schon mal mit der Kirsten äh Fiedler ein bisschen länger drüber äh gesprochen, das Thema auch schon ein paar Mal hier äh behandelt, aber ich denke einfach, gutes Material, um nochmal nachzuvollziehen, mit worum geht's eigentlich, warum ist das wichtig, warum ist auch diese äh Reform ähm auch durchaus
wünschenswert, ja, meistens, wenn man irgendwie Reformen hört, dann kriegt man immer gleich Angst
aber hier äh könnte eben auch durch etwas durchaus etwas drin sein, was einem die Nutzung von äh Diensten künftig insofern erleichtert, als dass man äh sie eben auch leicht wieder verlassen kann.
Auch mal was.
Ja. Kommen wir zur nächsten Reform.
Ja und jetzt blicken wir mal richtig nach Österreich.
Ja, schön die Österreicher Fraktion. Ja, ich äh.
Sehr sehr populäres Thema gerade in der Metaebene hier, also auf jeden Fall ist einiges zu holen grad.
Ja ja ja äh äh wir brauchen mehr österreichische Dialekt im deutschen Podcast, ich sehe das schon.
Das auch. Ja, ja, du könntest dich auch ein bisschen mehr anstrengen. Du bist viel zu gut zu verstehen.
Ja, hör auf, ich werde schon oft genug für einen Deutschen gehalten. Das ist nur.
Ist es so.
Ja, nein, ist nicht so, aber ich kann's trotzdem nicht anders
Egal, kommen wir zur zur anderen Reform, vor der man Angst haben sollte. Äh nämlich die Urheberrechtsreform, die gerade in Österreich diskutiert wird. Ähm zu Vorgeschichte, ähm wir wir hatten irgendwie schon
ähm seit geraumer Zeit eben so verschiedene Bestrebungen, das Urheberrecht in Österreich mal zu reformieren, nicht wirklich ein großer Wurf, sondern eigentlich nur Nachbesserungen, die notwendig waren, um um neuen EU-Richtlinien
genügend zu tun, aber im Rahmen dieser Reform ist eben auch ganz stark für eine Festplattenabgabe getrommelt worden,
Und am lautesten dabei war ähm die Lobbygruppe Kunst hat Recht
jetzt auch schon mehrere Male äh hier im Podcast und auf Netzpolitik Punkt org Thema war.
Ja so ganz klassisches Astro äh Projekt, wo also wirklich,
so getan wurde, als gäbe es hier so eine breite Bewegung äh in einer Künstlerszene in Österreich und äh beim genaueren Hinschauen wurde dann häufiger festgestellt, so na ja, also das scheint doch ein sehr orgastiertes äh.
Vorgehen zu sein aber nicht aus so 'nem Aktivität heraus sondern eben aus einer Lobby Unterstützung heraus.
Ja, das äh also Kunst hat recht, hat äh einen riesigen Negativteil, eben dass sie, dass sie die Künstler vereinnahmen und so tun, als wäre,
für Verschärfungen, für mehr Pauschalabgaben und alles wird total schlimm. Äh das ist so der schlechte Teil. Der gute Teil ist, dass
dadurch die Diskussion über das Urheberrecht in Österreich begonnen hat, die davor irgendwie wirklich nur einen sehr speziellen Zirkeln.
Passiert ist, ist auf einmal nach oben gefallen und auf einmal hatte man,
nicht in der Mainstream-Medien, aber zumindest auch in großen Teilen der, der Kunst- und Kulturszene ein bisschen eine Diskussion dadrüber,
man eigentlich will und wo der Schuh aktuell am meisten drückt.
Und dadurch hat sich auch irgendwie eine eine sehr kreative Protestwelle gesponnen also das,
Lustigste davon ist, dass Kunst hat recht äh in der letzten Woche den Wolfgang Lorenz Gedenkpreis für Internet freie Minuten von Monochrom bekommen hat
Das ist ein Satirepreis, der nach einem ehemaligen ORF-Intendanten benannt ist, der sich mal in einer,
Diskussion über das Scheißinternet echauffiert hat, was äh die Jugendlichen dazu bringt, kein Fernsehen mehr zu schauen.
Und seitdem ist ihm ein preisgestiftet äh und den hat dieses Jahr eben die äh die Gruppe Kunst hat Recht bekommen für ihr äh ja, technikfeindliches, realitätsfremdes Lobbyieren. Ähm,
Besonders lustig, wenn so die eine Künstlergruppe der anderen angeblichen Künstlergruppe einen Satirepreis für Bereich.
Das stimmt.
Ich glaube, da gibt's auch irgendwo einen Mitschnitt an.
Der ist aber nicht mehr, der ist nicht mehr der Intendant, ne? Also der der war mal.
Nee, nee, der, der, der war mal, der war mal, also der, der aktuelle hat sich, glaube ich, noch nicht zum Internet geäußert. Also, der, der ORF ignoriert.
Das muss, das muss ihm noch gezeigt werden sozusagen, ja? Man hat beschlossen, dass erstmal ihm vorzuenthalten und so. Nee, nee, nicht, dass das irgendwie noch einen Schock eintritt oder sowas.
Ja, du, die, die, die öffentlich-rechtlichen Medien in Österreich dürfen eh fast nichts mehr im Internet machen, insofern ist deren Präsenz da eh total eingeschränkt.
Ähm was was sonst noch spannend war dieses Mal, war so eine eine Studie der Arbeiterkammer
Ähm und es gibt ganz viele Studien zum Urheberrecht, von denen man immer wieder hört und das ist eigentlich immer sehr trockener Lesestoff, der der juristisch interessant ist, aber
ähm die Studie, die ich in meiner von der Arbeiterkammer, die äh ist recht erfrischend.
Kannst du mal kurz erklären, was die Arbeiterkammer ist?
Die Arbeiterkammer ist äh puh österreich ist ja ein Kammerstaat. Wir haben.
Wirtschaftskammer und eine Arbeiterkammer. Wenn du irgendwie selbstständig bist, bist du bei der Wirtschaftskammer, wenn du Angestellter oder Arbeiter bist, bist du bei der Arbeiterkammer.
Erstmal sozusagen auch so Zwangsmitglied und so, so wie das hier äh mit der IHK äh in Deutschland auch äh.
Genau, genau. Das ist einfach so ein Verein, wo du dabei bist, ob du willst oder nicht. Und die,
deine Interessen äh und in diesen Angelegenheiten so in netzpolitischen Dingen sind die eigentlich auch in den allermeisten Fällen.
Ähm sehr progressiv unterwegs und und haben halt vor allem Konsumenten und Arbeitnehmerinnenschutz ähm als als ihr Interesse erkannt. Also dort, wo sie das Internet verstehen, haben sie auch eine recht gute Meinung dazu.
Ähm aber diese Studie, die sie eben herausgegeben haben letzte Woche, äh betitelt mit äh Urheberrecht im Alltag, äh äh schafft es irgendwie an an sechsundvierzig Beispielen aufzuzeigen, wo,
heutzutage einfach der Alltagsgebrauch mit Medien schon ein Konflikt mit dem Urheberrecht steht.
Die gehen dadurch alle möglichen Lebensbereiche durch und zeigen auf wie ganz normale Menschen, die einfach nur logisch mit diesen neuen Medien und teilweise auch alten Medien umgehen, Verstöße gegen das Urheberrecht. Äh,
ohne ohne sich dessen überhaupt bewusst zu werden. Und äh das ist irgendwie eine sehr schöne Argumentationsgrundlage an derer man zeigen kann,
wie groß eigentlich der Handlungsbedarf wäre, hier endlich mal was zu reformieren. Und ich finde diesen Weg, diesen diesen Vektor auch ganz schön,
Sich mal an der Alltagsrealität der Menschen zu orientieren und nicht immer an irgendwelchen verkopften juristischen Texten, die die hier für Ordnung sorgen sollen.
Ja.
Sozusagen so ganz reale äh Beispiele, so wie Kindergarten, äh kopiert Noten, damit irgendwie alle mitsingen können für die Weihnachtsfeier, et cetera, all solche äh Beispiele, richtig?
Also die Quintessenz ist so ein bisschen, dass die Veröffentlichung heutzutage so leicht geworden ist und auch der Remix, dass äh es einfach überhaupt keinen Sinn mehr macht, da das zu reglementieren und ähm wo wo sie halt sozusagen als Fazit enden ist, dass wir,
neue Schrankenregelungen brauchen. Also, dass wir einfach sagen müssen, so, es gibt diesen ganzen privaten Bereich und bitte schön, das Urheberrecht hat den nicht zu regulieren.
Ja, da gab's ja wieder auch diese schönen Fälle von äh YouTube Videos, die dann automatisch wieder in so einem Take-Down äh landeten. Hier so mit der, so in Deutschland so beliebten
als GEMA-Sperre äh bezeichneten Takedown, Notes, äh äh wo dann so Bilder vom, also Live-Kameras.
In Russland heruntergenommen wurden, weil halt im Autoradio, wo diese Kamera, also Auto installiert, weil halt im Autoradio gerade Musik lief, die halt urheberrechtlich,
bla, bla, bla, erkannt wurde. So und dann durfte man halt auch erstmal nicht.
Beobachten wie ein Asteried die Welt vernichtet. Es ist.
Ja, es geht einfach nicht, weil da muss halt erstmal äh muss erstmal ihr GEMA-Gebühr bezahlt werden.
Ich glaube, es gibt nicht immer irgendeinen Sci-Fight, der diese obskure Realität.
Ja, also das, das sind halt genau diese äh Fälle und ich meine, wir, die wir da so ein bisschen mehr in dieser Diskussion äh stecken, kennen ja auch noch viele andere Beispiele so aus dem täglichen Leben, wo es einfach immer wieder absurd ist. Also wo sich, sagen wir mal, auch einfach
moralisch so recht einfach keinen äh Anspruch eines
in irgendeiner Form recht erhalten, Menschen ableiten lässt, ja? Weil das einfach an der Stelle nicht wichtig ist und weil's an der Stelle einfach auch nicht,
das Wichtigste ist.
Vor allem auch ein ein Mensch, der vor siebzig Jahren gesch.
Irgendetwas, was du hervorheben würdest aus diesem dieser Studie der Arbeiterkammer, von diesen Beispielen, die jetzt irgendwie besonders prägnant sind oder sollte man einfach nur mal empfehlen, da durchzublättern, um einfach selber.
Das ist was zum Blättern, das ist was, das man ganz leicht verständlich lesen kann. Ähm ich würde noch gern was zu der Reform selbst sagen, eben äh eigentlich ist das
so das Pendant so und zu zu eurem Leistungsschutzrecht in Österreich, das ist auch noch etwas, das die Koalition jetzt durchpeitschen will vor der Wahl,
es sieht aber schon so aus, als wenn sie das nicht mehr schaffen würde.
Wann ist die Wahl?
Auch im September, Ende September.
Ihr macht euch aber auch wirklich alles nach.
Ja, mein Gott, ich weiß gar nicht, wer zuerst war. Wahrscheinlich wählen wir gleichzeitig. Ähm.
Na ja, zweiundzwanzigster September ist es, glaube ich, in Deutschland.
Ja, achtundzwanzigster neunundzwanzigster ist bei uns.
Noch eine Woche hinterher. Erstmal gucken, was die Deutschen so machen und dann wird wieder hinterher.
Ja, das ist die Chance, wenn die Piratenpartei in Deutschland es noch schafft, dann hat die in Österreich vielleicht auch eine Chance. Insofern hast du absolut recht.
Okay, wollen wir mal gucken.
Ähm und ja, das das war's auch schon. Das wird auch irgendwie übers Leistungsschutzrecht reden, das erspare ich euch.
Ach, krass.
Maximal aus, dass das in ein nächstes Koalitionsabkommen reinkommt.
Alles klar.
Was auch noch so auf der Österreich-Agenda steht, ist äh Transparenzgesetz.
Tut sich aktuell sehr viel. Ähm da gibt's auch eine eine sehr schöne äh Lobbygruppe ähm auf Transparenzgesetz AT,
die es sich auch zum Ziel gemacht hat
ähm für ein Transparenzgesetz in Österreich anzutreten, auch nach dem schon oft diskutierten Hamburger Vorbild und irgendwie haben dies in den letzten ein, zwei Wochen geschafft, von irgend so einer,
Untergrundbewegung, die gemeint hat, ja, wir brauchen hier unbedingt ein neues, obskures Gesetz
hinzu so ziemlich die gesamte Regierungsspitze äußert sich positiv darüber, sagt, wir legen jetzt bald Entwürfe vor und müssen wir unbedingt noch in dieser Legislaturperiode durchpeitschen.
Das war ein wahnsinnig schneller Umschwung und natürlich ist jetzt mal die Frage, wie viel davon ist Lippenbekenntnis und wie viel kommt da, aber,
irgendwie an sich ist es schon mal ein gutes Zeichen, dass das die Politik das Thema aufgreift und.
Da tut sich jetzt eben gerade sehr viel so mit Diskussionsrunden und mit äh Gesetzen, die gewälzt werden und das Thema wird auch irgendwie gerade in den, in den großen Medien in Österreich sehr ähm breit getreten,
und das ist
ähm an sich einfach so so ein schönes Beispiel, dass diese Idee einer Transparenzgesetzgebung doch äh was zu sein scheint, dem man sich ähm nur schwer entziehen kann. Also es gibt eigentlich keine guten Gegenargumente.
Wie sieht denn die Situation aus? Ich meine, es gibt ja in Deutschland zumindest dieses, wenn auch sehr umstrittene Informationsfreiheits äh Gesetz, was ja zumindest schon mal so ein bisschen den Weg
gebahnt hat, wenn auch noch äh mit vielen Möglichkeiten für die Behörden da Hürden aufzustellen
gibt es eigentlich überhaupt etwas Vergleichbares in Österreich oder wäre jetzt dieses Transparenzgesetz überhaupt das erste Mal, dass irgendjemand
Karten geschaut werden darf.
Ähm das ist ganz lustig. Also wir haben in Österreich auch ein Auskunftspflichtgesetz, das irrsinnig löchrig und schwach ist,
Ähm was was an sich schon mal sehr viele Ausnahmen vorsieht und äh das Lustige ist da noch dazu, dass dieses Auskunftspflichtgesetz äh auf gleicher Augenhöhe mit dem Amtsgeheimnis steht.
Beides in dem Verfassungsrang.
Ähm und das Amtsgeheimnis, das das ist auch irgendwie so Sinnbild für die ganze Verschwiegenheitskultur in der öffentlichen Verwaltung
die dem Bürger auch nur als Bittsteller sieht und da diese zwei Gesetze hat noch dazu in im selben Rang stehen,
ist es einfach in den meisten Fällen gut dümpen der Obrigkeit, ob man in der das in seiner Frage eine Antwort bekommt oder nicht.
Das heißt ja, es gibt so ein bisschen etwas, rein theoretisch aber in der Praxis,
sind wir noch ganz weit weg von einem einem transparenten, gläsernen, maschinenlesbaren Staat ähm oder überhaupt ähm dass dass sich äh Politiker rechtfertigen müssten für ihre Entscheidungen. Auch da
ist einfach die, die Kultur noch nicht vorhanden und äh was auch ganz stark dazu führt, dass man heute überhaupt,
anfängt äh über Transparenzgesetz zu reden ist, dass man damit wunderbar ablenken kann von den vielen, vielen Korruptionsfällen, die Österreich in den letzten Jahren erschüttert haben.
Also das war wirklich bis in die höchsten Reihen
dass das ehemalige Regierungen, Minister und auch in Korruptionsforellen verwickelt waren und
die generelle Meinung in der Bevölkerung ist auch inzwischen so, die sind eh alle korrupt und es ist äh braucht da irgendwie auch ein Umdenken
und es wäre eigentlich die die Hoffnung und die Chance für eine Politik zu sagen, wir reagieren auf diese Vertrauenskrise mit mehr Transparenz.
Ja, aber da gibt's bestimmt auch genug Leute, die dann auch tatsächlich äh ausreichend zu verbergen haben, um dann solchen Tendenzen nicht unbedingt zu viel Sympathie entgegenzubringen.
Das wird man sehen, also ähm ich glaube rückwirkend werden sie das nicht machen, weil dann hätten sie den ganzen Dreck von früher aus ihrer eigenen Partei natürlich in der Öffentlichkeit und das wollen sie nicht.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich ein Kompromiss, den man am Ende auch einfach eingehen muss, um da überhaupt vorwärts zu kommen. Nach dem Motto, okay, meinetwegen, äh wir äh wir geben euch eine Teilandeste, aber jetzt möchten wir ganz gerne auch mal äh zuschauen.
Ich wäre zufrieden damit.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Äh und letzter Punkt ist noch, ich will auf meiner Lieblingshomepage zu sprechen kommen, äh frag den Staat Punkt AT. Äh es gibt jetzt eine.
Ja. Deine neue Lieblingshomepage. Die gibt's ja noch nicht so lange, ne?
Wessen Lieblingshomepage.
Ne, da also das ist deine neue äh Lieblingshomepage. So lange gibt's die jetzt noch nicht.
Genau, genau, die ist jetzt auch so
eben ein, zwei Wochen, das ist alles so eine kurzfristige Welle, gibt's die und äh ist eben ein eins zu eins äh Frage, eine eins zu eins Kopie der deutschen Seite äh eben angepasst an äh österreichische Behörden und Gesetze
und da kann man eben Anfragen an an diese Behörden stellen in Österreich und.
Das heißt, das basiert auf diesem Auskunftspflicht äh äh Gesetz sozusagen.
Genau. Das, das, also wie jedes Staat, das bedient sich äh immer der der Besten zur Verfügung stehenden Gesetzgebung, um die Frage an den Staat zu stellen.
Und äh das Tolle ist ja, auch wenn der Staat nicht antwortet, kann man das auf dieser Homepage recht gut nachvollziehen und transparent machen.
War überhaupt ein interessanter äh Aspekt, dass man solche äh Auskunftshilfesysteme
quasi so als Expertensystem benutzt, um sich dann auch automatisch zumindest schon mal durch die ersten paar Instanzen, juristischen Dschungels durchzukämpfen, in dem äh
mit Abhängigkeit der Art und Weise, der Anfrage oder des Gesuchs
auch gleich einem herausgesucht wird, na ja OK da gehst du am besten hier lang, weil da werden dann irgendwann die Türen verschlossen sein für diese Art von Anfrage, dass man dann quasi so 'n,
so eine kleine künstliche Intelligenz äh schafft, um sich eben durch den Gesetzesdschungel orientieren zu können. Ist eigentlich ein interessantes.
Sowas würde man sich doch an vielen anderen Stellen auch wünschen, dass man so irgendwie das das staatliche User und dann dann eine schöne Zwei-Punkt-Null-Website hat, mit der man über die man mit dem Staat interag.
Ja, also ich denke, im Bereich Steuerstrublöcher gibt's äh sicherlich schon ein paar ganz innovative Anwendungen, die allerdings nicht so in der Öffentlich,
stehen so, aber klar, natürlich, das äh wäre eigentlich etwas, was man machen soll.
Ähm frag den Staat AT äh äh wer wer steckt denn dahinter? Also der Code ist ja dann sicherlich der selbe, der äh für frag den Staat
DE ähm verwendet wird, aber es muss ja dann sozusagen auch eine explizite Anpassung geben. Wer.
Genau, ähm da stecken die Leute von äh Transparenzgesetz AT dahinter äh und äh
der der Originalercode kommt äh von von Stefan Wehrmeier von der Open and Ole Foundation in Deutschland und die die technische Partierung in Österreich hat ähm der Finn gemacht, Markus auch so einer ähm von von dem Metallableuten.
Ah ja. Okay. Ja. Was haben wir uns für einen Schluss noch äh aufgehoben?
Äh ich habe noch eine kurzen Aufruf. Ähm wir haben ja hier in Österreich auch eine eine Kampagne zur Netzneutralität
auf ähm unser Netz AT und da gibt's jetzt gerade eben äh so einen, wie soll man sagen,
ich bräuchte Leute, die gut,
Netzwerk sich auskennen und das von sich behaupten und die Interesse dran hätten, Verstöße gegen die Netzneutralität zu messen. Ähm das heißt, hauptsächlich auf einer theoretischen Ebene zuerst einmal, was es für Möglichkeiten gibt, zu,
festzustellen, ob in einem Netzwerk zum Beispiel geschäbt wird, ob gewisse ähm Dienste schon,
vorne rein verboten sind oder Anbieter geblockt werden. All diese Dinge, ähm da suchen wir gerade Leute, die das ähm als Thema haben, die sich dafür interessieren, äh da ein bisschen Hirnschmalz und Zeit reinzustecken.
Ja. Könnte man ja vielleicht,
die ein oder andere äh Diplomarbeit machen aus äh solchen Sachen immer so als äh Anregung nebenbei, falls irgendjemand gerade mit seinem Informatik äh äh Studium zum Ende äh äh kommt und noch ein schönes Thema sucht, das sind eigentlich immer solche Sachen, wo man eigentlich sein Wissen sehr
umfangreich einbringen kann und dazu auch noch mit einem praktischen Nutzen
ausstatten, das ist ja bei Software eigentlich immer ein ganz interessanter Aspekt. Ähm fällt mir so nebenbei nur ein, ich,
grüble auch schon die ganze Zeit. Ich meine.
Von ähnlichen ähm Plänen oder Systemen sogar auch schon gehört zu haben, mir fällt's einfach ums Verrecken gerade nicht rein. Aber falls da jemand,
weiß.
Lab, meinst du das.
Das weiß ich nicht, ob ich das meinen der Name sagt mir jetzt nichts, ich hab nur grad so ein Echo, was ist das?
Das ist so eine eine Plattform, die hauptsächlich die Messdaten zu Netzneutralität husten und zur Verfügung stellen,
und die kriegen ihr Geld unter anderem auch von Google, was ja ein bisschen in Verruf bringt, aber da kann man irgendwie auf ähm einigermaßen komfortable Art und Weise die Daten von
den paar Netzwerktesttools, die es so gibt äh herausziehen. Wir haben das damals für Netten und Charity Map,
Org verwendet, wo wir so eine Weltkarte mit der Ist-Situation der Netzzentralität gemacht haben,
Das sind halt alles sehr oberflächliche Daten, also die Frage ist wirklich so, was ist denn theoretisch notwendig, um eine Aussage über die Neutralität,
Eines Internetanschlusses zu machen.
Ja und das eben so als permanenten Watch Dog, der einfach die ganze Zeit schaut, ob sie auch irgendwas verbessert, äh verändert hat et cetera.
Genau, weil, ich glaube, Zentralität ist einfach ein so verkopftes, komplexes, technisches Thema, dass wir das nur mit guten offenen Daten und guten Visualisierungen an die Leute herantragen können.
Das das wird erst dann irgendwie kampagnenfähig werden, wenn wir wirkliche Transparenz in dem Bereich schaffen.
Äh dazu braucht's einfach ähm Messtools, die die auch irgendwie beim User laufen können, die verständlich sind, die sowas wie den Wetterbericht über das Internet. Ist immer so meine Vision, weil.
Ja, ah, verstehe. Und ihr wollt das jetzt auch gar nicht auf Österreich beschränken?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, also das ist jetzt nur hier der Aufhänger, weil hier eben die Gruppe ist, die die sich konkret damit beschäftigt und ähm wir sind am Ende des Podcasts, ich kann das eher erzählen. Unsere Regulierungsbehörde hat uns gefragt
was sie äh die haben so einen Speedtest für Provider, den sie ausbauen wollen und sie haben uns gefragt, was man da nicht an Messungen zu Netzneutralität reinbauen könnte.
Und äh das äh abseits dieser konkreten Anfrage, was die umsetzen sollen an an Softwareanforderungen hat sich für uns dadurch auch die Frage gestellt, was ist denn eigentlich der
der optimal Zustand. Was wollen wir? Maximum Wissen über eine Internetverbindung. Um eine Aussage darüber treffen zu können, wie neutral jetzt ist oder nicht.
Das ist so ein bisschen das Mieter dazu.
Also man macht keinen Speedtest, äh man testet so ein bisschen, ob die Netze auf Speed sind.
Ob da irgendwie, ob da irgendwas braunes. Ja. Ja, okay, also wer äh sich hier vielleicht angesprochen äh gesprochen fühlt und Lust hätte, mal ein cooles System zur äh Überarbeitung von ähm.
Zur Überwachung von von ähm Internet Providern äh mitschreiben möchte, der kann sich gerne äh bei dir melden, ne? Ist das richtig sehr? Und wie meldet man sich bei dir am besten?
Am besten ähm Thomas at Luniger Punkt org oder einfach at Social Hack auf Twitter und so ziemlich allen anderen Kanälen.
Genau, jetzt auch auf.
Ja.
Fein, super. Dann äh haben wir's eigentlich, oder? Das äh war ein sehr schöner äh Rundumblick.
Ähm ja, nächste Woche werden wir dann genaueres wissen, was so mit dem Leistungsschutzrecht hier äh abgegangen sind. Es bleibt spannend. Äh,
Vielen Dank Thomas, fürs Einspringen hier. Äh
den Ninos und äh natürlich generell für die Berichterstattung aus äh Österreich, weiß nicht, hast du noch irgendwelche Termine äh treffen oder so, was so euren Lokalaktivismus äh betrifft, den du gerne noch teilen möchtest?
Ähm ich,
wie schnell du mit dem Veröffentlichen bist, äh morgen ist die U einundzwanzig, das ist so ziemlich die interessantste Diskussionsveranstaltung zum Urheberrecht im Metalabin in der Rathausstraße sechs ab neunzehn Uhr dreißig.
Morgen ist dann der achtundzwanzigste Februar zwanzig dreizehn. Mhm.
Ganz genau. Und ähm ansonsten aus dem Stehgreif auf Weiber T schauen, auf Netzfreiheit Punkt org schauen oder auf Web-Termine AT.
Okay, das packen wir alles noch mit in die äh Shownotes. Dann denke ich, machen wir jetzt hier den Sack äh zu,
Vielen Dank, Thomas und äh vielen Dank äh fürs Zuhören hier an alle und äh nächste Woche geht's wieder weiter. Tschüss.
Tschüss.